رساله لمن يهمه الامر فماذا وراء الامر من
تهديدات حركت
نحو الشرق الاوسط
الغواصه الامريكيه التي دخلت المنطقه منذ
يوم الخميس تعمل بالطاقه النوويه وهي
مزوده بصواريخ استراتيجيه موجهه انها وفقا
البحريه الامريكيه قادره على حمل ما يصل
الى 154 صاروخ كروز من طراز توماهوك وهذا
طراز من الصواريخ يصل مداه 2500 كيلومتر
ويمكنه التحليق على ارتفاع منخفض نسبيا عن
الارض
المهمه الرسميه للغواصه كما تحددها واشنطن
هي دعم الامن البحري والاستقرار في
المنطقه
وعمليا ستدعم الاسطوره الخامسه الامريكي
الذي يتخذ من البحرين مقرا له وتغطي
عملياته الخليج العربيه وخليج عمان والبحر
الاحمر واجزاء من المحيط الهندي
لا يكشف البانتاغول في الغالب عن مواقع
غواصاته في المياه الدوليه
خطواته النادره تتزامن مع تحركات عسكريه
اخرى في المنطقه محمله بالرسائل ذاتها فقد
ابقى الامريكيون على حاملات الطائرات جورج
اتش دبليو بوش والقطع المرافقه لها في
مياه المتوسط حيث الاسطول السادس الامريكي
[موسيقى]
وجاء ذلك كله بعد ايام من ارسال سرب من
طائرات اي عشره المقاتله لتعزيز القدرات
الامريكيه في المنطقه
يقرا متابعون في تلك الحشود جميعها تصميما
امريكيا على تنفيذ وعيد وزير الدفاع
بان اي هجوم على الجنود الامريكيين لا يمر
دون عقاب هي اشاره لا شك الى سلسله
الهجمات الاخيره على قوات بلاده في سوريا
وما تبعها من رد امريكي
لكن الاستراتيجيه كما يبدو استبدلت القصف
بالحشد العسكري والتلويح باستعمال القوه
عند الضروره في تحسب لهجمات مستقبليه
محتمله
تنقل صحيفه
ان ارسال الغواصه ياتي اثره تلقي معلومات
استخباريه تفيد بان ايران تهدف لتنفيذ
هجمات بالمنطقه قريبا وتضع الصحيفه ارسال
الغواصه الى الشرق الاوسط في سياق تحرك
الاوسع يقوم به البانتاجون لتعزيز القوات
الامريكيه في المنطقه وذلك لردع القوات
المدعومه من ايران عن تنفيذ المزيد من
الهجمات على الولايات المتحده وحلفائها
بحسب ما جاء في وولز
تمت من يضيف الى ذلك مخاوف امريكيه على
سلامه الملاحه التجاريه في مياه الخليج
وان كانت الدواعى فان واشنطن طورت هنا
بحسب خبراء عسكريين مفهوم ردع جديدا يقوم
على الانتشار الضخم والسريع ويشمل ارسال
قوات استراتيجيه الى المنطقه خلال ساعات
كل ذلك الحشد العسكري المتزامن جعل القوه
الناريه الامريكيه عاليه في المنطقه ومن
اتجاهات عده
[موسيقى]